look who's here ladies and gentlemen
Maria Menounos has arrived hi how are
you I'm great how are you
I'm I'm great I know that you're in town
technically you're still in town from
Wrestlemania yes yes oh my gosh how
great was it that was amazing I think
it's so fun that like you know cuz I'll
see you do the Hall of Fame and then
you'll be doing you did the watch long
this time with them right that was so
much fun
Pat McAfee yeah but I mean hello me in
the Big Show yeah yeah oh no big show
we're good together we had a lot of fun
I heard the big show went on and
immediately announced that they had
switched one of the matches to go first
yeah yeah it was supposedly AJ Styles
was supposed to be first I think and
that's who I thought I was doing the
watch along for right and so yeah and
then Big Show just like oh yeah they
switched it was like wow right right but
then you end up spending most of the
show out on the floor like always yes
and just Dan yelled at by fans I've
gotten a few tweets from people that
were upset I was standing up and I just
want to let everybody know who's
listening that I am very apologetic and
I turned around and I was like I'm sorry
they were taunting me and no I think
they thought I was taunting them and
being like [ __ ] I was like no no I'm
genuinely sorry I was too excited I
wasn't like paying attention yeah like
no time to do who knows so it was kind
of like glued to my seat for the rest of
the night like and then I would do that
like hover but then it what it really
does is it makes it look like you're
sticking your butt out at everybody
right no I've seen you at these shows
you get extremely enthusiastic yes like
to the point when you're in your own
world Yeah right right did you have a
favorite moment I mean obviously the
women's match I got really emotional and
there was a woman behind me who was
getting really emotional so the two of
us were like starting to tear up because
it's been such you know such a journey
for the women's division and to see them
out there main eventing was so cool and
of course I see Becky Wynn was amazing
yeah and we've become friends and so I
was super psyched about that and of
course Shane McMahon always like I saw
him backstage and I go change do you
always have to almost like like kill
yourself like do we all
boys have to be in fear for your life
yes one of those things where you think
that if you were in like this high
dangerous situation and you survived it
you're like I'm never doing that again
yeah but he's like well I survived it
I'm just gonna keep doing that over and
over again I know there were a lot alike
injuries this time around too like I
heard Ms got his head stapled and I saw
Shane with a huge black eye and Rana
broke her hand and yeah everybody showed
up a lot of bloody elbows I saw front
row but you almost ended up with bloody
elbows I was at the Hall of Fame you
know I'm sitting there and they're with
Jess and I watch this guy jump out of
the crowd he's wearing like a
Rastafarian hat and he grabbed Bret Hart
and you know how wrestling is it's one
of those things where for a second you
have to go
is this a bit yeah you don't know but
real quick it was like oh my god this
isn't a bit and the guy tackles Bret
Hart and immediately Rhonda's husband
Travis jumped onstage and if I'm right
and a bunch of the wrestlers jumped
onstage and I'm like this is the last
place in the world that you want to do
that yeah and I look up at the center of
the ring I'm like how did Keven
Undergaro get in the ring with them and
there he is officiating the whole thing
like making sure that everybody's in the
position that they should be in did you
just turn around and see that your
husband had fled and and well I think
you missed a little bit of this yeah I
examine this like the Kennedy
assassination okay I feel like three in
the morning I was so basically you know
I see this guy chasing in after Brett
and again I didn't understand and Travis
Ronda Rousey's husband literally if you
watch the videos he spears him as this
dumbass Spears Brett mhm
and Natty's instincts were brilliant
because she saw him coming she protected
Brett went down with him and so soon and
I I grabbed my phone I started
instagramming I'm like oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god and then Kevin's
gone and so Kevin climbs into the ring
who lifts Brett up pushes him over to
the side then he realizes oh we got to
get this guy out of here he's like
Murray I just kept hearing this I mean
you could see and this guy was super
dumb and so kevin jumps out of the stage
to pull him
a chain and of course everybody else so
I run over to Stephanie I'm like
Stephanie this is real right like I cuz
I'm so like scared to like screw
something up and she goes it's real stay
out of it like stay back here and then I
see Kevin in the middle Mike no way so I
started running like a psycho I pull
Kevin out and he's like you get out I
don't know you get out and then myself
so mad I make you you hurt my friends so
Kevin is trying to like ease the tension
somewhat and you're like no I'm getting
in there yeah I'm getting in there I'm
Boston just totally happened it just
came out and it was funny because people
were tweeting they're like the long
haired female attacker was Marie I don't
know what I thought I was gonna do among
seven foot tall 400-pound Giants but I
was gonna just felt it yeah you felt the
rage build-up yeah that's the thing you
don't go in and be that disrespectful
and survivor and someone who had gone
through a stroke and ten a.d you just
don't do that and a roomful of wrestlers
is probably the wrong crowd to do it
yeah our family yeah no not happening
yeah so Marie let's talk about from that
to right well I'll tell you that the
same protective instincts that you have
and that Kevin has your dog has yes
right and I know that and I know that
because I've been there and I've met
your dog and your dog likes me
it's a giant German Shepherd likes you
Maximus likes me yes we walked around
the house but the vibe that I was
getting from him is that any moment cuz
yeah cuz he needed pets the whole time
the entire time yeah I didn't even
petting him and being nice and I saw his
eyes the whole time and he would just be
looking up at me like try something yeah
just try something like no no we're
petting we're still good and even if I
stop petting I knew that that wasn't an
option
don't worry you saw my husband he's a
hero he just he would save you right but
we were on good terms where we stayed on
good terms and it was great but you you
guys have been dog people forever as
long as I've known you certainly and and
years and years and years before that so
the fact that you're involved with the
Beverly Hills Dog Show is not not a
shock it seems very fitting yes it's my
third year and
I remember when I was working Eddie they
asked me to do it and I was like so I
get to hang out with dogs all day yeah
that would be amazing
rather than hang out with you guys yeah
with the dogs perfect anyway so we I
remember vividly that first year I was
so giddy getting to see all of these
different breeds I mean it was
unbelievable I was a kid in a candy
store and they were really kind and
allowed me to gush and squish and kiss
and mush and and then get around to the
actual job of interviewing people right
so so I've been doing it for three years
and yes it's the Barbra wheels dog show
presented by Purina and what's cool
about it is it's different from the
other dog shows because we are bringing
the celebrity to it so Ashley Tisdale
was there with her little dog Maui but
my favorite was Shawn white Olympic gold
medalist comes in my jaw dropped to the
ground he comes in with his little
Terrier I think it's a 40 Leroy Leroy
the good boy I think he's called and
he's got his own Instagram account and
they were wearing matching outfits oh my
god both in pink
no no but seemed he had pink sunglasses
just like his dad the dog was wearing
pink sunglasses really the good boy was
wearing it's everything everything you
have to look it up on Instagram it's so
cute so we had the celebs we had the
dogs it was so much fun it's it's a
family tradition so it'll be on this
Easter Sunday yes at 1:00 p.m. and we
also have the now show on NBC thank you
for for that and then we also have the
National Thanksgiving the National Ducks
on Thanksgiving Day so you have two
different holidays now with Big Time dog
shows beautiful dog shows and you don't
bring a Maximus are you I wanted to but
he wants to eat everybody that's what my
thinking was that there would be
especially you're talking about Shaun
White and his little tiny thing like
that Maximus would eat that dog no see
Maximus is really good with other dogs
oh he wants to eat the people he wants
to eat the people anybody who comes near
me he might eat and so I usually bring
Winnie with me yeah when he's my little
poodle who doesn't want to eat people
right yeah and I've seen I've seen
Maximus make snap judgments like he just
decides in the moment yeah oh no oh yeah
my cousin in the bud he did yeah my
cousin came over it was all good and
then he got too close to me and like
hovered over me and then he bit him in
the bud yeah that's probably the best
case scenario with maximum is quite
frankly yeah I mean he could do some
damage if you want Maximus is a hundred
and thirty pound just beast but he's my
everything and so I love dogs and so
does Purina and so it's a perfect fit
yeah I love and Whitney's gonna be in a
commercial spot really yeah so you'll
get to see Winnie she's such a superstar
she gets her own commercials now so
you'll see her and in the show because
we have this everybody in the Minu in
the Menounos household is working
everybody's got to work yeah everyone's
gonna contribute so if you post a photo
with your dog and you hashtag it every
dog is a star
hashtag every dog is a star yeah I got
that right I got Purina they are gonna
be choosing photos to put in the show so
you just got to tell us why your dog as
a star that's amazing
my dog misbehaves a lot but she's very
pretty dog so maybe I'll I'll try to get
in on yeah what do you have to do do you
remember why I have to tag every dog has
tag every dog is a star uh-huh and then
explain why she is a star and tag Purina
said he see it and of course it take /
yes yes
well maybe I'll do that maybe I'll take
Lyla Garrity and I'll get her in her
most photogenic space and I'll try to
get involved in this
see I think you if you put if you put
your baby in there and that I think you
like double the odds of like getting in
there yeah I think one of them cute kids
- you got to remember about my kid has
not there's not one photo of my kid on
social media haven't done that that's
right no but I know like I look at the
photos that I have and I'm just throwing
away likes you know I mean I'm leaving
likes on the day are you scared I'm not
scared I just don't want him to I he
hasn't chosen to be public you know name
and so I don't want I was even if he
about I posted I went with Jess
obviously the Hall of Fame yeah she's
seven and a half months pregnant but I'm
one of the rare photos of Jess I posted
a picture the two of us oh I thought you
were afraid of the unborn baby photo
look at the unborn baby hasn't decided
yeah no but but she's protected inside
the womb so she's fine okay but I was
like I usually don't do this I usually
don't post stuff this personal but it
got like the most likes ever and
everybody was super nice about it so I'm
probably just being paranoid for nothing
but yeah okay you try your hang on to as
long as you can exactly just he's just
gonna get cuter and cuter right and so
it's gonna get harder and harder and
then one day he'll just start his own
Instagram account and I'll be like what
are you doing yeah speaking of
documenting things yes you have been
going through like so much and it's
amazing how much you're doing based on
how much you've been through you know of
course you know the world knows that
your mom still going through the still
going through brain cancer right and
that's something that you and Kevin and
everybody around you has been working on
and working with her tirelessly for how
long now it's gonna be three years in
August that's incredible yeah God God
thankfully yeah
giving us a lot of time and at the same
time what a year ago maybe a little more
now
a year and a half ago yeah you find out
that you have a brain tumor mm-hmm and
have to get it removed and go through so
while you're working with your mom going
through brain cancer do you have to have
brain surgery mm-hmm
to have a tumor removed and oh by the
way you're doing everything else yeah
that you do just to try to stay afloat
and you guys are doing a documentary is
that right yeah well I was filming every
step of the way just don't have it just
to have it you know the second I got
diagnosed I flipped the camera on me and
Kevin we were in Mexico in a parking lot
and your vacation no we had taken my mom
in for treatment we were taking her to
alternative treatments because they said
her tumor was growing I see and I found
out once I had Chuck them in it was a
really really bad time obviously when
you find out that this tumor is growing
I was really scary and then of course my
doctor was like I don't know how to tell
you this but you have one too and so I
flipped the camera on
and did like a confessional and then
from there I kept filming everything
different things along the way the
doctor appointments and such and mainly
so that I could remember how I was
acting how I felt because it's easy to
like kind of change the story later like
I want to remember how I handled it
right and that was really important to
me and and what I was thinking and stuff
and because my life moves so fast I
forget totally so I document everything
anyway
and so when I was recovering from
surgery our CTO at afterbuzz and Kevin
strong all the footage together said a
lot of it and I had a lot of footage of
my mom as well and it was a little doc
and so I ended up connecting which
oberlin jar the goat of documentaries
absolutely who did Tony Robbins most
recent one was it the I am NOT your I'm
not your guru yep and he's done a ton of
everything Ted Bundy stuff yes didn't
you do the West Memphis Three yes yeah I
mean he's brilliant so I just had dinner
with him to ask him some advice and then
I started telling him my story of what
I'd been going through and he was like I
I want to work on this and so he was a
little busy with Ted Bundy at the time
so now we're connecting and we're gonna
figure out how to take it from where it
is and I don't want it to just be about
you know oh she had a brain tumor
everybody knows that we all know with
that what we've been going through but I
want to show people kind of what gets
you there and I think it's more of like
a message to women that was Kevin who
had just this brilliant idea he does
Maria every speech you're going out and
talking to women you're telling them all
of these things that they need to hear
do it in the doc so that everybody can
hear it you know where as women were
everything to everyone and nothing to
ourselves we are so type-a we have to
make sure we get the flowers to somebody
on their birthday we got to make sure we
you know plan the vacation we're in
charge of like everything yeah and then
top of it we have to make sure our hair
is diet and our nails are done and we
look amazing and somehow we can't age
and there's a lot of anxiety and there's
a lot that goes into being a woman and
we have to be perfect and we have to
balance it all no one ever asks a guy
how do they balance it all mm-hmm they
ask women every single day plus when
people go how do you balance at all I go
I have my wife do most of the stuff yeah
that's the way you do it yeah you guys
just it's just a different thing and so
I want to kind of show women and people
in general the new life perspectives
I've had the changes that I've made in
my life so that I can live a happier
healthier life I want people to focus on
their health more and to realize that
you can do a lot for a while it
eventually will catch up with you
so tonally not exactly the same as the
Ted Bundy tapes not exactly no although
Kevin does want to kill a few people
along the way I can only imagine oh
that's why Doc's are amazing right right
people he thinks are responsible for a
little bit of what's going on so maybe
that'll be in there too
no no there's people we've all mentioned
there's people they know who they are
yes they and I hope they're apologetic
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]